I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle tonight thank you for being with
us
The Establishment versus DeSantis that
is the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now the GOP nomination fight hasn't even
begun in Earnest but many of the Bush
Republicans already seem worried
we thought they'd Seen the Last of
America First style populism after 2020
but that was just wishful thinking
it turns out that Ron DeSantis Florida
Governor popular won by 20 points who
they thought was anti-trump in tone and
maybe in substance he sounds more
America First than Ukraine for as long
as it takes earlier this week DeSantis
called Ukraine a territorial dispute
that is not in our Vital national
interests he slammed Biden's virtual
blank check to Ukraine and open-ended as
long as it takes commitment without any
objective benchmarks for success
he noted that this war distracts from
our many other challenges
and he rejected further escalation with
long-range missiles or f-16s because the
nuclear risk he believes is unacceptable
with Russia
the pro-war Coalition heard this and
they went wild now you might have
thought that DeSantis had pushed for I
don't know Russia to join NATO as a
reward for invading Ukraine
the anti-woke guy Ron DeSantis his ideal
is Putin's Russia where there are no gay
people where there are no women in power
where you know they're all Christians
that's how he wants to see the world
that's the world that's why they love
Putin and they love autocrats
now these are the same people by the way
who would still have a
have us laying down in Afghanistan he
worked for Romney ambush
now always wrong never in doubt and
they're now putting Relentless pressure
on DeSantis to change his View and then
give in to the warhawks to say this
doesn't matters to say that war crimes
don't matter he's going to go beyond
Ukraine Putin if you don't get that
you're not listening to what he's saying
this is a chance to stop Putin before it
gets to be a bigger war and China is
watching
yeah China is watching Lindsay and
they're undoubtedly in disbelief
that once again America is depleting her
resources and her munitions
and taking your eye off the ball in Asia
where Taiwan is hanging in the balance
yet the pro-war media the same people
were anti-war during Iraq
they're right with Lindsey Graham and
Romney and all the rest they're enraged
over to Santa's Ukraine stance as well
now the Wall Street Journal called it
his first big mistake and accused him of
surrendering to the trumpian temptation
of American Retreat ouch
meanwhile The Washington Post tried to
paint the GOP shift away from a more
pro-interventionist foreign policy as
somehow a repudiation of Reagan
conservatism and foreign policy and he
warns a potentially seismic consequences
for the conflict and the party itself
yeah I would say seismic but in a good
way
and by the way the posts attempting to
defend Reagan's Legacy would be like me
trying to defend Hillary Clinton's
Legacy it's absurd they hated Reagan
Malibus is absurd as Senator Graham
saber rattling on the Russia's shootdown
of our drone
we should hold them accountable and say
that if you ever get near another U.S
set flying in international waters your
airplane would be shot down what would
Ronald Reagan do right now he would he
would start shooting Russian planes down
if they were threatening our assets
incredibly irresponsible and inaccurate
Ronald Reagan for whom I worked believed
in peace through strength now that was
the Cornerstone of his 1980 campaign
that meant that a strong U.S economy was
essential for America to have a strong
robust foreign policy that was backed up
by an even stronger U.S military
establishing a real peace must rest on
the firm underpinning of a strong
American economy
tragically the weakened state of
America's economy has significantly
affected our ability to have the
strongest possible foreign and defense
policies our inflation is especially
undermined the dollar and is upset World
Markets
and when they question our economic
reliability they begin to question our
reliability as a strong Ally
now sadly that's a situation we find
ourselves in today America is weak
because we made ourselves weak just as
we did in the mid-1970s
after being bogged down in Vietnam
remember for years we neglected our
domestic economy and allowed runaway
inflation to eat up American paychecks
and Destroy American optimism
but in the final weeks of the campaign
Reagan's closing argument included a
warning we cannot continue letting
events and crises get out of control
we must through sound management and
planning be in control so as to prevent
being confronted by a crisis
this requires a sound economy a strong
National Defense and the will and
determination
to preserve Peace and Freedom
for a new president
turn this economy around
any Republican who thinks that the 2024
election will be determined on woke
issues as interesting as they are and as
important as they are is going to find
himself or herself disappointed in the
end
but let's face it we've tried Lindsey
Graham's way we've tried the Bush's way
this is not personal
it didn't work
the war Fanatics and the GOP and now in
the Democrat Party they don't seem to
realize that we're not living in the
America of 1988 when Reagan left office
today we're 31 trillion dollars in debt
and many of our essential Supply chains
are dependent on China
it happens to be our greatest adversary
that makes sense of course our schools
teach our kids that America was founded
on racism and our economy is so weak
that when the FED tries to raise
interest rates to fight inflation you
get Bank runs
now most of the old GOP supported and
enriched China and weakened America and
now we're on the verge of one of the
most serious geopolitical crises we have
ever faced
now already it seems that China not the
U.S is considered the go-to superpower
for negotiating peace and new alliances
that's a change
and if we don't get our economic house
in order this Dynamic will be
irreversible
we're going to find ourselves with zero
leverage around the world when we need
leverage most
so the last people that Ron DeSantis
should be taking advice from are the
very people who help get America into
this mess
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else